so the headline here so far is that
before Elon Musk bought it Twitter
wasn't so much a social media site as a
Honey Trap operated by global
intelligence agencies including our own
one of the very first things Elon Musk
did was fire all the spies who worked at
Twitter then he fired a lot of other
people too including the entire PR
department the HR department and a lot
of other useless baggage who weren't
helping the company do anything worth
doing and what happened next we asked
him
[Music]
met a shrinking pie obviously for most
of the traditional media companies and
made them more desperate to get clicks
to get to get you know get attention
um
and
he has made them when you know when they
were when they were in a sort of
desperate State they will then tend to
really push uh headlines that get the
most clicks whether those headlines are
accurate or not
so it's resulted in my view I think
probably I think most people would agree
a less truthful less accurate news
so
uh because they just got to get a rise
out of people and
I think it's also increased the
negativity of the news because uh I
think we humans instinctually uh respond
more to that I think we have an
instinctual negative bias which
which kind of makes sense in that like
uh
if
um like let's say you're uh like it's
more important to remember where we
where was the lion or where was the
tribe that wants to kill my tribe then
where is the bush with berries yes like
one's like a permanent negative outcome
and the other is like well I might go
hungry so meaning that there's an
asymmetry in
um
sort of involved asymmetry in negative
versus positive stuff
um and and also historically the
negative stuff would have been quite
proximate like it would have been near
represented a real danger to you as a
person
um if you heard negative news you
because historically you know like a few
hundred years ago we're not hearing
about what negative things are happening
on the other side of the world or on the
other side of the country we're only
we're hearing about negative things in
our village
um things that could actually have a a
bad effect on you whereas now we're
hearing about we mean the news very
often seems to attempt to uh answer the
question what is the worst thing that
happened on Earth today
any wonder why you said after reading
that you know do you read any
Legacy Media Outlets I mean I really get
most of my news from Twitter at this
point it is the number one music news
source I think uh only in the world at
this point what percentage of your staff
did you fire at Twitter
one of the great business stories of the
year I think we're about we're about uh
20 of the original size so 80 left uh
yes so I mean a lot of people
voluntarily sure sure but but it's 80
are gone from the day that's correct yes
so how do you run the company with only
20 of the staff
uh turns out uh you don't need uh well
that many people to run Twitter but 80
that's a lot
um yes uh over I mean if you're not
trying to run some sort of uh
glorified activist organization uh with
with it and you don't care that much
about censorship then you can really let
go of a lot of people turns out
how many others without naming names but
how many I had dinner with somebody who
runs a big company recently said I'm
really inspired by Elon and I said you
the Free Speech stuff he goes no the
firing the staff stuff
um how many how many other CEOs have
come to you
um
to talk about this I I spent a lot of
time at work uh so it's not like I'm
meeting with lots of people this is what
I what actions I've taken
um and um
but I think we just had a situation at
Twitter where it was absurdly
overstaffed you know so it wasn't uh you
know like you could say like what does
it really take to operate Twitter
um
you know most of what we're talking
about here is a group text service at
scale
um like
how many people are really needed for
that you know
um and if you look at the you say like
uh what has been the product development
uh over time with Twitter and you're
like so like you know years versus
product improvements and it's like a
pretty flat line so what are they doing
you know it took a year to add an edit
button that doesn't work most of the
time
I mean this is I feel like if it was a
comedy situation here you know
um
you're not making cars you know uh it
was very difficult to make cars
um or get Rockets to orbit so
um you know the real question is like
how did it get so absurdly overstaffed
this is insane um
so
anyway that's and it's clearly working
um in fact I think it's working better
than ever it's about we've increased the
uh responsiveness of the system by in
some cases over 80 percent we're trying
to make make sure the most trusted place
on the internet the least untrustworthy
place on the internet I don't think
anyone should trust the internet but
maybe we can make Twitter the least
untrustworthy like I said try to
get uh the truth to the people
um as as best we can
when Elon Musk took over Twitter the
company had something called a human
rights team
there was no measurable increase in
human rights around the world in fact
Twitter was doing its best to crush
human rights starting with the most
basic which is the right to say what you
really think
Elon Musk in his spare time runs the
world's biggest rocket company
couldn't resist asking him if he ever
sees anything out there in space that's
not human so we did subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight